the jurogan experience i just watched uh
uh joakim phoenix in joker
and
he's
he's a very charismatic actor
and i was thinking oh god because he
carried that whole movie on
single-handedly it's a dark dark movie
and it has to do with resentment this
man who was forced to be nice by his
mother yeah you know who turns out to be
absolutely crazy and abused him like mad
when he was a kid and and then he
becomes this role model for the
dissemination of complete catastrophe
into the entire society it's a story of
kane in in part but phoenix really
carries that and part of the reason that
he does that is because he creates a
compelling character who's sympathetic
like you can be sympathetic to him
because he really did have a hard life
like
really hard but phoenix
is an extraordinarily charismatic person
partly because he's so unbelievably he's
masculine in his features
and carved
but he's so graceful
every single thing he does in the entire
movie is a dance like he's conscious of
every single movement he makes every
turn of his head is
conscious it's dance-like and you can't
take your eyes off it and a lot of
stellar performers had that ability to
integrate male performance had that
ability to integrate that feminine grace
into their masculine character